speaking of deep ballerstatus you guys
brought a killer instinct season two yes
it's at tomorrow October 15th wide yep
yeah new characters yo got two new
characters at launch we got TJ combo and
Maya did the launch trailer today which
I'm sure someone from your fine site
will put up for everyone else it's
probably up there already tog in there
an embargo yeah no it's that's embargoed
you're safe is it not is this live yeah
oh shut it down no um Dave house cinder
ripped or coming back a whole bunch of
good stuff I look at it I oh there we go
there got it up nice crew it's is like
an outfit yeah a stream holy cow what
happened to tjs arms he's all caught up
and he's cybernetic now he ripped he
ripped out all the ultratech that was in
him right and now he's under percent
organic he was sick of people giving a
crop about it's got he's got he's
beefing with ultratech maiya Maya Maya
yes the 3d modeling software my is
pretty godlike are we gonna get to play
some of these yes I think what we'll do
is mean g bailey oh let's do some
matches and show some TJ Maya stuff just
do a couple okay here's what she can do
here's what it is here's the stages and
then I will body him on live stream for
the world to see all right let's get to
attention alrighty sir me and me and
Pope can I can share cast yep we are
gonna get to your game later on yeah
just in case people of things yeah I'm
just hanging out turn up I've got my own
game guys he just sits here and drink
Starbucks for like an hour we want to
just show my real quick and talk about
yeah while you're doing so Maya nobody's
really gotten their hands on her until
tomorrow's launch people have had early
access from TJ combo and she's a pretty
good character she based basically on
all her daggers that she uses they're
called temperance and vengeance and
basically doing a fireball motion will
throw one or the other at you and if
they block it powers up her dagger okay
now with their daggers when you throw it
it's not like a typical fireball you
have to actually go back and get those
daggers so the premise is like when she
has her daggers she's super scary and
super powerful but to charge up the
daggers she kind of has to get rid of
them so gonna throw one it's right there
that kind of like so the HUD there in
the lower right corner you see the every
time so if I block go and throw them
again the daggers get more pips so now
they're fully charged and can do
something is there any way the other
player can reset them just like I can't
pick a call to use them in combos you
can pick up them by pressing through
punches or if you do a roll or any of
her comp mid combos let's chill gather
them so I'm gonna give her those bad
boys all right just wanted to point out
I noticed the GF largest trees in the
back Huff hunt that get in there I'll
shout out submit combo I can do this
stop walking Dave out there Oh wrong way
oh my god I'm saying goodbye sir so the
med combo should be able to get her
daggers back this is TJ stage right and
uh yeah all right now it's not she has a
nice cool little air gap she has to have
just down and fierce punch as you're
jumping in the it's actually great mix
up to the only way if I if you're biting
my it you have to duck to get out of the
way and you can cancel out of the jump
in do it overhead so it's like it's kind
of like a 50-50 mix up really and when
her daggers are powered up you can end
your combos was level for ender if
they're fully powered does a whole ton
extra damage the cool thing about her is
her mobility not many characters have
this where she can roll forward and jump
in the middle the roll jump faster and
higher so that way you know I want to
get my dagger back and just go and get
it back pretty much it's incredible how
much of the sort of the nuance and he's
fighting games is down to that sort of
stuff like you're no stranger to it at
all with your work at CEO like it's
funny how like when you're making these
games now because the fighting a
community is so big like you are you
literally making it for vacuum unity and
not like just the everyday you know dude
wants to pick up well not at all for ki
like ki very deliberately some of the
characters are really easy to pick up
and play Ling like characters like Maya
and like Jago a very traditional kind of
like execution motions like quarter
circles are sure welcome short emotions
or whatever there's characters like TJ
or like saberwolf who are really simply
just back and forth and up and down on
the snake and the thinking being that
you know we want as many people to try
the game as possible one make it as
accessible as possible so FB some
characters are kind of like easy that
anyone can kind of get in there and use
and so but we still do want like you
know a lot the super super high skill
ceiling crazy execution to combo stuff
for you know people have been doing this
their whole lives like Alex here so was
there a character would have seven
characters or eight or nine characters
in a seasoned woman you guys launched
the end of last year thurs 888
characters yet a shadow Jason which is
limited yeah we haven't talked about in
the season two yet or if we
but uh so we did announce the trailers
eight characters we have publicly said
that there's four returning characters
yes original series and then four new
ones which we give you a hint at in the
trailer itself so we'll be talking about
we've announced that we're having a new
character or a character to season two
once every month okay mother was Maya
cinder rip director on TJ as well yeah
yeah okay cool so this is a former
turning than for other characters which
people haven't seen quite yet and then
what about the stages is there one for
each one of those yes or you got one
more in there yeah there'll be one for
each new character as well now this I'll
show you is the first stage to have a
stage ultra in the game y'all chillin oh
sweet love you and I'll mess it up yeah
I don't need it can I sit up cool thing
about her is just the tricks that you
can do with their daggers it's been
super fun for us to work on cuz if
anyone has been familiar with iron
galaxy and some of the stuff we've done
like we started off doing a lot of ports
for capcom like third strike marvel
capcom origins darkstalkers and do those
partially just because we really like
those games a lot and really love
fighting games have a lot of people
there who just kind of live and breed
that stuff then you know divekick last
year and then you know last week on
next-gen and get a chance to do
something like this that is like you
know a wholly original like legitimate
work in the fighting game space has been
super rewarding for everyone else to do
spend crazy fun it's not like a bunch of
responsibility when you got given like
an i feel like this he's kind of told
you know here's something of a bunch of
people really like don't mess it up yeah
it was it was kind of double whammy for
us because you know Doug double helix
did season 1 of this right and they did
it I mazal there it is and now it's time
for everyone's like Field of Dreams that
was my only does my only creative
guidance in this whole project as I said
make that like Field of Dreams yeah and
those guys did an amazing job and so
like one kind of like not wanting just
to meet what they did but try to surpass
it and a lot of ways to was super super
challenging but you know without the job
they did we wouldn't even be here today
right now so shoutouts to double helix
and those guys want to show them of it a
thief so TJ TJ's got a couple of kids is
most unique mechanic he's got recaptures
for the first time so um with season one
you could do a lot of like launching
characters in the air but that would
kind of Entercom
can do a lot with it and so TJ can
actually kind of keep combos going with
this recapture Walker slim sorry haha
Alex they're demonstrating combo
breakers thank you out combo but his
bread and butter is really the power
line so he's got this move it's kind of
like back a little bit yeah she's got
like this full screen attack but he's
got a bunch of things again view off of
that so you come in and you can grab off
of that we captured and then so off of
that you can also bet back up please so
you can also fake it cancel out of that
you can roll do things and then finally
my favorite is the knee out of that and
so he's got a lot of options to get in
really close if he's confident you're
not going to you know do anything like
say Maya throws a dagger that's all bad
ideas but when you do the shadow version
of this it's actually got armor so
actually if you throw in go get those
and throw it at me when I'm doing the so
up too far but yeah she could they be so
the [ __ ] that versions got armor so you
can kind of get through tax and get all
the way in and the Tigers only charge up
when the block hopper this is you yes to
block for that to happen but it doesn't
change the usability you can always
throw them any way you want in the air
on the ground now her instinct mode is
really cool when you activate instinct
mode her daggers always returning her so
you can do cool stuff like that and then
the middle the combo basically I had my
como meet her up but yeah so I'm
throwing a I throw this Adam I have
enough time to get all the way over to
him to finish a combo so that's really
cool very tricky so if he's blocking
that I'm coming in as he's blocking and
it gives me the chance for a couple
mixed up at anyone has any questions in
the chopped ab by all means a sentiment
first one coming in London asked with
gfp industries be in every iron galaxy
game from now on we're all part of gfp
industries GOP industries lives inside
all of us at all times like the bottom
line was yep the industries I'm not
gonna say that out loud was on Dave can
you explain to a dummy like me what is
the deal he punches for all what is the
deal with the seasons thing is it is it
is it just a different way of saying
it's part two yeah so basically there
was a you know so i guess for
who don't know anything about killer
instinct on this forum is so it's a
free-to-play game right so you can
download the whole thing for free it
kind of works on like a legal edge and
style basis where there's one character
that's typically free and you can try
them out and then if you wanna swap that
out you can buy like five bucks per
character or you can buy the whole lot
of bundled content for cheaper and so
yeah so it's kind of just a way to
demark those bundles essentially right
so you can get all the season one stuff
in a bundle all the season two stuff in
a bundle I'm sure when we're done with
season two of the bundle all that stuff
together a discount as well yeah it's
kind of is too easy way to kind of d
marks meres bundles Oh is there any fun
to keep going with this bad boy season 3
you know a lot of it we would love to
out the user base is growing in it well
it can only be going on the Xbox one
yeah i mean it's it's there's this
element to this of where it it seems
like free-to-play it's just gonna get
better and better and better on consoles
as people keep buying them buying them
by you let's go to my stage real quick
really off and so yeah so it seems like
it's got there's a real good chance that
he's gonna grow and grow and grow as
long as we give them compelling stuff to
keep doing you know so i really hope we
get to do season three but we probably
the reality is we probably won't know
about that for quite a while when kind
of get the numbers in and see how this
is doing yeah so I mean that's one of
the things that sucks about game
development right is like hey I want to
do this thing and this thing and this
thing in this thing oh but no one bought
the last thing you'll get to do any of
that now you go cry in your room for an
hour I it so I can stay with iron galaxy
forever and ever yeah this is actually
one thing jus Bailey's employment is
contingent on there being a season 3 so
if you think he's got what he's a smooth
looking character over here on the couch
I don't know why you would think that
would say hypothetically you did don't
screw that some people is that
confirmation that there won't be a dive
kick to then yeah oh I make that game
it's only an ActionScript anyway so he
can just that's cute with the flash
jokes that's cute
headed by hey the bun yeah but so is
that actually a background you were a
fighting game champ uh so I've been a
you know I've been playing street
fighter mortal kombat growing up played
a lot of killer instinct to in the
arcades so i've always been a competitor
playing it and i started my own
tournament series in orlando called CEO
do its differently to a lot of a lot of
other organizations you guys use the
rings and stuff right i use the ring yet
been done before but i like to make it
the theme because i'm a huge wrestling
fan and our generation of fighting game
players are from the NWO Attitude Era so
I brought errands like oh this is crazy
so I see my stuff a lot around that
that's why I first met Dave actually
yeah yeah when I met Adam keats uh Adam
Hart who is the lead Colin designer for
this game who created divekick you know
I saw the game like bring it to my event
let's check it out I told put me in the
games like why like I get a big head and
I went around it's like you're in the
game so and that's how I met Dave and
then you know yeah working for the first
time my experience to baileys actually
being a little modest this tournament is
the second biggest fighting game
tournament in the world only second to
evo Wow and it's growing like crazy man
right so I should open with that part
it's start out you know 300 people five
years ago it had 28 under this year you
know a big deal but where can people
find out more go to ultra dash combo
calm for the official forums and if
you're there is a website going up its
up right now yeah we are remodeling for
dash combo excuse me ultra hyphen combo
com I'm the lead moderator on it so
anytime gonna reach out to me on twitter
co je vais le we're always listening
that's the beauty of working these guys
is relaying the community and their
thoughts about the game I sent it
straight over to Microsoft so and coming
from the fact that i've been playing
fighting it for 20 years i oh whatsapp
in and out and go hey this could be a
problem or hey they really love this
let's add to that so is that where you
get bigger arms like that he's gotta
play look like again I do CrossFit so
haha god damn it just lied to me who's
winning this looks like a mafia yeah I
was talking the whole time need I get
free dinner tonight sweet so thank you
mama thank you
you